this is a simplified depiction of the
course of the fashion of facial of or
the seventh nerve also known as the
lower specialis it arises from the
bounds basically it has four nuclei this
is the nucleus of practice solitarius
this is the motor nuclei of the brachio
tunic lat
this is the salivary lachrymatory
nucleus this is these are two nuclear
and I have shown them as combined
salivatory nucleus and the lacrima
triopia now the facial nerve arises from
the Ponto medullary junction this is the
pawns and this is the Megillah it arises
from the point of adrenal Junction and
it is attached to this inferior border
of the pons by two routes with sensory
and motor route and the motor route
arises from the motor nuclei and the
sensory route arises from the nucleus
tractus solitarius and the Salyut relax
between nuclei and the pennant arises
from the lower border of depositor eyes
is just medial to the addition of the
ears hub that is the vestibule or
cochlear nerve now the basic outlay of
the facial nerve is that that data as
this course is divided into four parts
talking about the first first part and
this is the intracranial part which runs
from its origin up till its entry into
the internal acoustic meatus and this is
approximately 15 millimeters and the
second part it is the inter temporal
part which is further divided into many
parts now the intro temporal part
basically started
starts when the nerve enters the
internal acoustic meatus the nerve
enters the internal acoustic meatus
along with the vestibulocochlear nerve
and then it travels inside the internal
acoustic canal this is known as the
inter canonical part then it reaches up
till the geniculate ganglia
now this channel Italian is also known
as the genome of the patient now where
the patient up turns posteriorly in the
medial wall of the middle here now in
this genome the fashion of fashion of
gifts
the fibers for the lachrymatory clan now
this is known as the superficial greater
superficial petrosal nerve from its
origin in from this genicular ganglion
these fibers turn up into the middle
cranial fossa and then they pass they
pass through the foramen lacerum this is
the foramen lacerum and then move
forward they relay into the Teleco
Palatine gangway on this is the canyon
for these nerve fibers then the
postganglionic fibers arise and then
they supply the lachrymatory gland which
also supplied some nasal glands and some
Palatine lands on according to its
original course the vision of them runs
posteriorly it turns posteriorly and
runs in the medial part of the middle
ear inside the bony canal that's why I
have shown this as a dotted line it
turns posteriorly this is the vertical
segment and then it turns on the
posterior wall of the middle yet this is
a middle ear cavity it's like a cube
then on the posterior wall of the middle
ear this is the horizontal segment of
the facial nerve and this is very
important and because the facial nerve
here gives two branches the first is the
nerve to the stability s this supply is
the stable real muscle and the purpose
of this know is that this day period
muscle stabilizes the stay piece and
which prevents the hyper movement of
these teepees and paralysis of this
nerve leads to hyperacusis now the
another nerve that the efficient of
gives in this segment is the quarter
timpani branch now this branch runs in
the middle ear cavity and then it exits
the middle ear cavity through the petrel
tympanic fissure here and then it joins
the lingual of this lingual nerve is
basically the branch of the mandibular
nerve which in turn is a branch of
trigeminal nerve
this runs forward and then it divides
from the lingual nerve and
it's fibers relating to the
submandibular cambium and from the
submandibular candy on the porcelain
fibers arise and they supply the
submandibular and sublinguals library
lamps now this nerve is also the
quadratum B'nai branch but it travels
along the lingual nerve this branch
basically brings the taste sensations
from the anterior 2/3 of the tongue this
relays along with the lingual nerve into
the trigeminal nuclear continuing to its
original course the facial nerve then
runs downwards and exits the middle ear
from the stylo mastoid forum in here now
after exiting through the style of
mastoid foramen this part is known as
the extracranial part opportunity it's
and division into the main Rogers now
this after exiting through the style of
mastoid foramen the facial nerve gives
here three branches the first is the
posterior auricular branch the second is
the nerve to the posterior belly of the
digastric and third is the style of
mastoid forum style mastoid muscle to
the style of mastered muscle these are
the muscles which are derived from the
second break a large then the original
trunk of the fusion of moves forward and
it enters into the substance of the
parotid gland the facial nerve in the
parotid gland lies between the two and
the superficial in the D part of the
petal it land here the facial nerve
divides it into its main five branches
this is the temporal branch this is the
zygomatic branch this is the buccal
branch this is the mandibular branch and
this is the survey garage and these
branches supply the muscles of facial
expression and hence the course
terminates here thank you guys for
watching my video please subscribe to my
channel for further updates